so geht aber ich blicke seit
samstagnachmittag sehr zuversichtlich
sogar optimistisch auf das jahr 20 21
bin voller hoffnung in spa rational
begründete hoffnung dass wir 20 21 auch
riesige schritte machen werden die
pandemie zu besiegen
besondere anders für diese zuversicht
ist das heutige thema es war dass alle
derzeitigen diskussionen und
erkenntnisse in der wissenschaftlichen
gemeinschaft nahelegen
schon sehr bald wirksame impfstoffe
verfügbar zu haben
aber ganz wichtig dass wir auch eine
hohe akzeptanz dieser impfung in der
bevölkerung erreichen wir wissen dass
wir um eine ausreichende immunität in
der bevölkerung zu erreichen
etwa 70 prozent der menschen dass 70
prozent der menschen mitmachen müssen
sich impfen lassen
das braucht zum einen wurde bereits
erwähnt zeit
es ist aber auch ganz entscheidend dass
die wissenschaftliche gemeinschaft in
einem schulterschluss mit der politik
den engsten die existieren adäquat
begegnen
dazu braucht es vertrauen dazu braucht
es akzeptanz und diese basieren immer
auf transparenz klare informationen und
guter gemeinsamer kommunikation
nach derzeitigen umfragen sind etwa 50
bis 60 prozent der menschen bereit sich
impfen zu lassen das heißt wir müssen
zusätzliches vertrauen in der
bevölkerung gewinnen was die thema das
thema wirksamkeit und sicherheit der
impfung angeht wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren